visitors to the beaches of Punta Cana
are treated to a Caribbean island
paradise here the developing country of
the Dominican Republic presents its
prettiest face to the world more than 3
million tourists from around the globe
flock here each year but what's good for
the economy is bad for the environment
the hotels here produce over 800,000
tons of carbon dioxide every year as
much as a thousand flights from Germany
to Punta Cana the group or Punta Cana
has been trying to combat this kind of
environmentally damaging tourism the
tourism group has operated hotels and
golf courses in Punta Cana since 1969
and since 2012 it's also run a biogas
plant now de menezes who heads the plant
says it incinerates up to 20 tons of
organic waste a day merci moment are a
la planta ahead of you we built the
plant to be able to produce our own bio
mass market another pen demo that way
we're not reliant on others like those
who determine the fuel prices the group
of Ponte connors gardens trees and
plants produce a large amount of organic
waste after drying in the Caribbean Sun
it makes the perfect fuel for the
biomass boiler and it generates enough
heat and steam to operate the hotel
laundry
Benjamin hula Feld is from the US he
came here four years ago and has become
a passionate environmentalist una failed
works for the company's ecological
foundation he's developed a method to
compost food waste from the hotel
kitchen this is a the California red
wiggler worm the compost dead organic
material just by digesting it naturally
and they produced this high quality
natural organic fertilizer that we're
able to use they use the fertilizer on
the golf courses where its nutrients
help keep the green screen
in the capital Santo Domingo such
environmental protection schemes are
sorely lacking eighty-five percent of
the country's economy is reliant on
fossil fuels so the government has
developed a new climate strategy it's
pushing a project that originated on
city streets as the roads are full of
potholes drivers here go through lots of
tires but they have no trouble finding
buyers for their old ones since the
cement industry here began using them as
a source of fuel the tires are burned in
special low emission incinerators say
makes the country's largest cement maker
is thrilled with the results we are
bringing on a daily basis around 1,600
times per day so each time we use a tire
we are reducing our primary fuel
consumption meaning that is going to be
less emission less co2 and more
environmental friendly the Dominican
Republic is trying to reinvent itself as
a pioneer of Environmental Protection in
the Caribbean it wants to be seen as a
country with white sandy beaches and
green credentials